hey everyone so my name is Luke
um I've been working on the object
detection API for care CV for about the
last year and I'm really excited to
share what we have with you today
um I have posted a link to the slides in
the chat but you can find it right up
here too you should be able to just see
it on my screen please
um so yeah this link should work for
anyone but
anyways so first things first I do want
to quickly say that this API is still
experimental we're still finalizing some
details uh as to like some of the
um parameter names and you know little
quirks here and there and stuff object
detection is a pretty complicated task
and so there's a lot of ambiguous
decisions so just adds up the API is
still evolving a little bit but it
should be pretty stable
so a really quick step back to the
motivation of what right why we like
decided to write an object detection API
uh so around a year and a half ago I was
not working on care CV
um and I was working on a few different
object detection pipelines
um I did that with Keras and tensorflow
and it was really painful uh there was a
really difficult
well I faced many difficult issues in
debugging it and in getting the really
state-of-the-art results at the time uh
using tensorflow and Keras a lot of this
has to do with graph execution and stuff
like that but some of the key pain
points I faced I probably spent like
sixty percent of my time making sure
that bounding box formats were aligned
between various components uh when
you're looking to assemble a
state-of-the-art object detection
pipeline you often have your boxes in
different formats whether it's X Y X Y
where each one is you know represented
by a different coordinate or maybe X Y
with height where you have four numbers
the top left and then the width in the
height or maybe it's like the center
width height where you instead of the
top left you at the center you can
imagine how managing this gets really
tricky uh between different projects and
unfortunately there are actually good
technical reasons to use each each
format at different stages in the
pipeline and so this is a really
burdensome to and and uh developers so
that was one of the big things I wanted
to design the API around another one was
augmentation so when you rotate an image
unlike classification you also have to
update the labels in classification you
don't have to update anything it's just
it's still a picture of a cat most
likely you might you know if there's a
cat you might crop it out probably not
though but if you crop even like crop or
stretch or just Road aspect ratio
anything you have to adjust your
bounding boxes so this was really
annoying
um
yeah an object detection you often want
to be able to perform inference over
variable size images you want agnostic
filters to the
resolution or I guess the size within
the image of the object like even if a
bus is shranked down a little bit it
should still be able to detect that bus
uh bounding boxes are inherently ragged
in that there's a different number
between
each image one image might have a
hundred bounding boxes one image might
have five and this is like inherently
really hard to represent In Like A
computation graph at least in all the
modern deep learning Frameworks and then
the last one the difficulty I really
faced was metric evaluation so really
the reason I list all these is basically
just to say like object detection is
really hard there's a lot of really
really complicated problems here have to
solve along the way and I hope to
show you an API today that I think
solves all of these and I believe it
solves a much more elegantly than any
other solution that exists today in a
much more modular way and easy to
maintain way so some feature highlights
we have like TPU compatible training
Loops which is really great and really
difficult to do with bounding boxes
because of that inherent raggedness I
mentioned where there's a different
number of boxes per image you can't fit
those into a dense tensor because your
second dimension you'll have your batch
Dimension and then your second dimension
will have a ton of mismatched numbers
um you know you can make this work on
TPU by padding with negative ones and
masking out certain values and the
losses and stuff like that but it's
really annoying to do that if you are
writing your own object detection
pipeline so we do that internally for
you and it makes it uh TPU compatible uh
we have like train time metric
evaluation in the computation graph
which is really really hard to get right
it might not sound that difficult but
this was probably the hardest part of
the whole API like I I think I spent
like a couple of months really getting
this to work and getting the numerics
right on a mean average Precision which
is a very
long to describe metric I can provide
some links to anyone interested in
reading about that but it's very hard to
do in a computation graph
um and uh yeah we have like native
support for ragged bounding box inputs
which I'll show off in the demo and uh
easily composable bounding box
augmentations and I'll also show this
off of the demo
um some like API highlights are you know
we have a very explicit management
system for bounding box formats to
prevent you from shooting yourself in
the foot so to speak and uh you know get
giving boxes in the wrong format to the
wrong components and stuff we have a
very modular API which
um it's kind of hard to show off unless
you know you peel a layer or two back
for the models but it's very modular and
you should be able to use pretty much
any component in your own model with no
issues and then we also have yeah native
pre-processing and augmentation layers
and very readable model implementations
so
just to really quickly show off some API
like highlights like why why I make such
a big deal out of the bounding box
formats is like you have if you have
this layer right here right like which
is a random Shear it shares the image
this way or this way or on the y-axis
like it's it's sort of like rotation but
um a little mathematically go for it and
you you might wonder like what Bounty
box format should my boxes be in and in
pretty much every object detection in
the project in existence there's just a
either a standard or you just have to
like read the doc string or figure it
out and you have to like visually debug
whether or not it's working usually by
plotting your bounding boxes on a few
images and showing them with matpot lib
or plotly or whatever uh so we address
this instead by making all of our
augment or all of our object detection
components support every single bounding
box format and instead you specify which
format you use
and this is really nice because as you
compose across multiple components
whether it's the augmentation pipeline
the data loading pipeline or the actual
model itself it becomes like really
obvious when you look through and you
see oh why why is this one x y x y and
this one X Y with height it's very
obvious that's a bug and you can very
very quickly run this down and run down
these sorts of issues which I make a big
deal out of this because I probably
spent 60 percent of my time on my
several object detection workflows I
built last year
um just debugging bounding box format
issues so this is a really nice API
decision that was a little maybe
controversial but I think we're very
very happy with
um so yeah this is consistent across all
of our components and now I'm just going
to show off like a few common tasks and
jump right into a demo to like not bore
you too much with slides
um so one like you can assemble an
object detection like augment
augmentation pipeline just like this
um like this is you know doing a lot of
this state-of-the-art augmentation
techniques it's a random flip distorting
the aspect ratio in like this jittered
resize layer is actually very well
optimized for object detection you might
not realize it but the way you resize
your images in the training Loop for an
object detection pipeline matters a lot
um and then this last one mix up
actually makes quite a big difference
too and you simply blend the pixel
values of two images together as you can
see here it's like you can't really see
what this box is around that's because
the pixels are Blended at such a low
rate but the models actually learn to
become more sensitive to Features by
being trained to detect like for example
there's still a train in here it's just
uh the pixels are very much Blended out
in the background and this yields to
higher scores on your evaluation set
actually if you do this during training
and so doing this stuff like all of
these you know the flipping the aspect
ratio Distortion the jittered resize and
mix up like you know historically this
has probably been like a thousand lines
of code like in all this right or it may
be a little bit less if you very
specifically code it for your project
and your input pipeline but you know it
you can do this in like 10 lines of code
which is just like awesome super super
awesome
um
so that's one thing uh the another thing
is you know here's how you assemble a
model uh like a retina net for example
um you just give it a number of classes
a backbone which can be basically any
care CV model we're still working on
getting some of this state-of-the-art
backbones for the model uh you can read
more about that in the actual red and
that publication if you don't know what
that means
um and then it also we have like some
other nice things like you can provide
any set of pre-trained Weights that
comes with care CV so there's this nice
integration between the classification
side of the project and the object
detection side of the project and in the
near future we're going to have
self-supervised pre-trained weights
which have a much better performance on
transfer learning tasks and stuff like
that than anything else that we know of
right now
um yeah you can do things like only
fine-tuned the feature pyramid Network
by disabling training for the backbone
and all these things like there's just
like a lot of basically 99 of users can
probably get by just by using our you
know the notebook I'm going to share at
the end of this presentation but the
point I'm trying to make by showing all
these different parameters and stuff is
we also expose all the little nuts and
bolts if you do want to customize your
bottle
um
yeah you can create Coco metrics like
this uh very very easy in the past this
has been something that's quite painful
uh almost everyone uses Pi cocoa tools
to evaluate cocometrics not a very good
user experience it's a package that was
written for the cocoa Challenge and I
think it's like 2011 or something like
that and has not been updated that much
since but most people rely on it to make
sure their numerics are identical uh
between you know for publication
purposes or comparison purposes so we
actually have a very highly accurate set
of Coco metrics that work in the
computation graph and they're pretty
performant I spent a lot of time getting
that working and you can just use them
like any other charismatric and so like
when you go to compile your model same
way you do a normal Keras model just
classic the only difference is you might
have multiple losses because there's
classification loss and box loss
um and yeah you can give it whatever
Optimizer you want whatever list of
metrics you want and it all just works
with Native Keras apis
uh inference is super easy you can just
save your weights like you would with
any model and you can load your weights
like you would with any model and just
run predict and this gives you bounding
boxes for those images so as you might
imagine if you're trying to create an
application that actually does this on
the Fly
um you can very very easily load weights
at a server startup time and just run
predict or you know on your mobile
device whatever it might
um so here's some examples you know it's
just what it some predictions might look
like this was not a particularly tuned
model but you can see it's like yeah you
just run predict and it gives you a
general area of where these things might
be
um and so last but not least I have a
demo in the in this collab notebook I
can copy this link over to the chat
again and I'm gonna just open it here
though
[Music]
um
cool so it's actually I was actually
running fit because I didn't uh
I didn't let's start the training job
early enough to have it be done by now
which is totally fine but the point is
the code
um but so yeah this notebook shows off
how to do everything that you might want
to do with character's object detection
API
so we start off by installing I have a
couple patches that I made for this
presentation because as I mentioned
we're still finalizing some API details
and uh but yeah install a couple pit
packages
um sort out our Imports here
and then we actually can remove that
um
next I just show off how to load the
data so here are you know we're loading
Pascal VOC which is just a standard
object detection data set uh it comes in
this you know TF data format which is a
dictionary with a million different Keys
um basically to make your own object
detection workflow work that uses Kara
CV this is basically the only thing you
need to reproduce for your own data set
you have to write a function that
packages your data into this format
where you have images and one key and
bounding box is another key in a
dictionary and you should be able to
copy paste the rest of the notebook from
here down and train like a very powerful
object detection model you might want to
hyper parameter search a little bit and
stuff like that but the general workflow
should be here
um
yeah here we assemble an augmenter which
is just kind of like a sequential model
this will probably be removed before the
true release of uh Cara CV's object
detection workflow in favor of a
sequential model but as you can see here
like this is super super composable
um you know like right now we have
gosh what well so I'll go ahead and
actually rerun some of these cells so we
can start from the top but
so you know for example if we want to
remove mix up uh and introduce Mosaic
instead just so we can see what that
looks like we can just you know comment
that out and comment it in which like
this might seem like very intuitive but
that's the whole point right like this
is these historically bounding box
augmentations have been very very hard
to compose
um and so this is actually pretty great
so we can show this off here
and let's see if it worked with the
mosaic
ah okay so I okay funny story I
interrupted the training script and that
um makes inference mode turn off so I'll
actually need to restart this runtime
just
a quirk I'm still working out that you
shouldn't worry about but
it makes the augmentations not apply
basically is the the takeaway there so
yeah I will import everything load the
data set again and this time it should
work
while we're waiting for some of this
stuff to run is there any way to take
questions while we're here
so yeah you can see it's yeah uh mapping
to the augmenter here it's like the
graph is all constructed and
now it should have the Mosaic of the
different images
oh man it looks like I'm on the the
wrong Branch so yeah I guess the Mosaic
is not quite prepared yet I thought it
was merged in but I think the pull
request to make Mosaic work is still not
quite merged yet
um the point is these layers are very
composable the launch is coming in a
couple weeks here and all these quirks
will be sorted out by that
so yeah we'll just rerun that you'll be
able to see at least the mix-up versions
which are the Blended ones uh Mosaic is
like a yeah so you actually this one's a
much better example than the one in the
slides you can see like the faint
silhouette of the cat here across this
image and so it actually trains it to
detect that as a cat despite these other
bikers in the background makes for a
much more sensitive detector that
detects many more boxes which is pretty
interesting
um and then here's the eval set so yeah
looks about like you'd expect an eval
set too
um
and then
yeah the last thing we have to do is
just construct a model
which we can do right here and compile
it with some metrics like we do here
and yeah give it any sort of normal
Keras callbacks you want
um and then you can just call fit like
you do with any other Keras model
um because I already ran it before we
can actually go ahead and load the
weights so we can get some decent decent
results from what was going on before uh
or what we so what we had the trading
job when I started the presentation from
here are
some sample detections so you can see in
here
we're just running model.predict like
you would with any Keras model like it's
just I guess the beauty of the API is it
just very much conforms to the Keras
modeling API which makes it very easy to
work with and very easy to reason about
um
yeah the reason this is taking a little
while is it the first time you run any
Keras model it has to trace the graph of
the underlying model but subsequent runs
of this same function would be very
quick like
you know on the scale of a tenth of a
second probably less
so
should Trace pretty soon here okay there
we go so it's done done tracing
cool so yeah I mean this was not done
converging or training
um but you can see it's starting to
learn what the underlying training
distribution it got both of the cows it
got one of the chairs got the horse in
person also thought this was a cow but
it's okay
um but yeah it's it's starting to come
along and this was only like four or
five epox in so it'll definitely get
there so we can continue training by
Running Fit
um and then the last thing I wanted to
show off is you can configure your
non-max suppression operation pretty
easily too with care CB and you do that
by uh constructing a non-max suppression
prediction decoder which is just a
concept we uh invented or it's just like
a layer a normal Keras layer basically
and you can give it any sort of
parameter you want like IOU thresholds
to prune over confidence thresholds to
prune over whatever and so maybe if we
run the same thing over the uh the data
the
got the data set we had here perhaps it
will prune out this cow detection or
something like that so
yeah like it looks like it well it looks
like it pruned out more than just this
cow detection by increasing the
confidence threshold so if you want to
get optimal scores usually you have to
play with this quite a bit this uh
non-max suppression operation you
usually have to tune into very
aggressively
so
yeah we could keep keep playing with
this but uh yeah I mean the model is
also not converged yet so it will
continue to just get better and better
as we allow it to train for more epochs
though yeah I mean a little a little
short on the presentation but this is
the uh this is the API and the beauty of
it is is that it is pretty easy to show
off it's um like it's just native Keras
apis that solve common object detection
tasks and yeah I mean you can just run
fit like you do with any other Keras
model and it can learn to solve an
object detection problem so we got a lot
of nice debugging Tools in here too like
there's a lot of little nuances in
object detection like encoding your
ground truth boxes to Anchor boxes and
training targets and uh we expose all
that information to you there's gonna be
a very extensive uh tutorial overview of
like how to use the API and that will
tell you how to expose and access all
the different Nuts and Bolts
so
yeah I mean if anyone has any questions
that would be great but this that's
um that's the Kerry CV object detection
API at this moment
um seems a little simple but it's all
there's a lot going on under the surface
that uh
I think you'll be very thankful for once
you start using the API a little bit
especially when you compare it to other
existing Solutions uh the front on the
front of modularity in particular I
a lot better than any